SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROW.
ALL. OF ROD GILL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTESI. DELHI. GOD. THERE ARE
ALSO EGM. GLASER. GOAL. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAYERED LI.
MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR M. NEWMAN.
WHEN NELO. PA. TOTINO BROUGHT
RUBIO. THEY ARE TO SKINNER.
SMALL CUEVAS STERN. UMBERG.
WELL. WIENER. WELL. ACCOR
PRESENT COLLEAGUES MEMBERS.
PLEASE GO BACK TO YOUR DESK. WE
ARE BEGINNING RIGHT NOW. WERE
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS ON
THE ROW, AND THEN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN MICHELLE SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN, AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG.
LET US REMEMBER THAT WE ARE
ALWAYS IN GOD'S PRESENCE. AND
TODAY I'D LIKE TO PRAY IN
GRATITUDE FOR ALL THOSE WHO ARE
OR HAVE BEEN FASTING FOR RAMADAN
AND LENT AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF
THE BAHA'I FAITH. WE'RE INSPIRED
BY THE OUTER MANIFESTATION OF
THEIR INTERIOR DISPOSITIONS FOR
THE BENEFIT OF HUMANITY. AND FOR
THOSE OF US WHO MAY HAVE SLIPPED
UP A BIT LIKE MYSELF. WE TAKE
COMFORT FROM OUR GOD'S
INVITATION IN THESE WORDS OF
RUMI? COME, COME. WHOEVER YOU
ARE. W WORSHIPER. LOVER OF
LEAVING IT DOESN'T MATTER. OURS
IS NOT A CARAVAN OF DESPAIR.
COME EVEN IF YOU HAVE BROKEN
YOUR VOWS. 1000 TIMES. COME YET
AGAIN. COME COME. AND SO
GRACIOUS GOD. WE THANK YOU FOR
LOVING EACH OF US AS IF THERE
WERE ONLY ONE OF US. UTILIZE IN
THE UNIQUENESS OF OUR BEING.
EACH ONE A SPARK OF YOUR
CREATIVITY. YOU ALLOW US TO
BRING THE WHOLE OF OURSELVES TO
ALL OUR ENCOUNTERS WITH YOU. MAY
WE DO THIS HONOR FOR ONE
ANOTHER. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME. AMEN. TO UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. YES. OK? THIS. YOU.
YOU.
RIGHT? SOMEONE CALLED IT. 10
HUT. I COULDN'T MOVE AFTER THAT.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA DEFER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. BUT I
DO IF YOU DID NOT KNOW, UM, IF
YOU HAVEN'T CELEBRATED, WE HAD
TWO BIRTHDAYS YESTERDAY
YESTERDAY, SENATOR ASHBY AND
SENATOR DIAO CELEBRATED THEIR
20TH SECOND BIRTHDAY YESTERDAY.
PLEASE CONGRATULATE THEM. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL BE
MOVING ON TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FILE ITEM 24 S¼ B 136 IF THE
SENATOR IS READY SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. IN BILL 136 BY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACT RELATING TO ME
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
HAVE TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR WEINER. YOU MAY PROCEED
AND COLLEAGUES IF YOU PLEASE
STOP TALKING. UH, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. UH, COLLEAGUES.
UH, S¼ B. UH, 136 IS THE MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATION. UH OR M èC
Ó, UH, TAX LEGISLATION. UH,
THIS BILL MODIFIES THE TAX ON
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WE AUTHORIZED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET BY INCREASING THE AMOUNT
ASSESSED ON MEDICAL HEALTH PLANS
WITH ANNUAL ENROLLMENT BETWEEN
1.25 MILLION AND 4 MILLION
PEOPLE, UH TO $205 PER ENROLLEE.
UH, IT ALLOWS THE TO DRAW DOWN
NEARLY. THE BILL ALLOWS THE
STATE TO DRAW DOWN NEARLY $1.5
BILLION OF ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS THAT WILL HELP
OFFSET THE NONFEDERAL SHARE OF
EXPENDITURES IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM BY RELIEVING THE GENERAL
FUND OF COSTS RELATED TO ME.
THESE CHANGES, UH TO THE M èC
Ó TAX, AS WELL AS THE USE OF
RESERVE FUNDS FROM THE EXISTING
TAX WILL HELP SHRINK OUR BUDGET
SHORTFALL. UH, BY APPROXIMATELY
$3.8 BILLION. THE BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY LANGUAGE GOVERNING
EXPENDITURES OF THE INCREASED
REVEN. FROM THE M èC Ó TAX
THAT ISSUE, THE EXPENDITURES
WILL BE ADDRESSED IN A TRAILER
BILL TO BE CONSIDERED BY THIS
BODY IN THE JUNE BUDGET. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. COLLEAGUES
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? YOU
WANT TO SHARE? WHAT? YOU WERE
TALKING WITH YOUR COLLEAGUE
ABOUT SENATOR GROVE. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. UH, YOU KNOW, COLLEAGUES.
A DEAL WAS MADE LAST YEAR ON THE
M èC Ó TAX. THERE WERE A LOT
OF US WITH FINANCIALLY
DISTRESSED HOSPITALS, PROVIDERS
THAT PROVIDE EXCELLENT HEALTH
CARE TO OUR COMMUNITIES. UH WE
PROMISED THESE RESOURCES IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
QUALITY HEALTH CARE IN THIS
STATE. UH I HAVE HUGE CONCERNS.
UM, REGARDING THIS MECHANISM TO
BROUGHT DOWN THE FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND USE THE M èC Ó TAX THAT
WAS GENERATED AND VOTED ON BY
ALL OF US TO PROVIDE DOLLARS TO
AGAIN OUR MEDICAL PROVIDERS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE HOSPITALS
AND NOW IT'S GOING TO BE DRAWN,
USED, DRAWN AND FEDERAL FEDERAL
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE BUDGET
DEFICIT. I REALIZE WE DO HAVE A
BUDGET DEFICIT, AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS
ADDRESSED, BUT I DO HAVE HUGE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION GIVING YOU
A REASON WHY I'M LAYING OFF ON
THE BILL UNTIL I CAN SEE SOME
DETAILS THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
PROVIDE CARE AND SERVICE IS IN
MEDICAL SERVICES, Ó BGY  N
SERVICES AND ALL THE SERVICES
THAT ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS USE
, UM, IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
EXCELLENT HEALTH CARE ARE, UH,
THEIR RATES ARE STILL PROTECTED
AND THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHTS THAT
WERE PROMISED TO US LAST YEAR
WHEN WE VOTED ON THIS TAX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR DALI YOU RECOGNIZE?
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. YOU
ARE DOING A GREAT JOB TODAY. UH,
I ALSO TO, UH HAVE WAS IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND WANTED TO RISE AND
SPEAK ABOUT. UH UH, THE M èC Ó
, UH, TAX. I ACTUALLY HAVE
SUPPORTED EVERY SINGLE M èC Ó
TAX. UH UH, IN THE PAST, AND THE
REASON I SUPPORTED THOSE WAS
BECAUSE THE MONEY, UH, ACTUALLY
WENT TO HEALTH CARE. SOME OF IT
DID GO IN THE PAST TO THE
GENERAL FUND. I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT, BUT IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
WE'RE FACED WITH TODAY WHERE WE
HAVE HOSPITALS ON THE VERGE OF
CLOSING. UM AND I TRIED TO GET
SOME ANSWERS DURING OUR BUDGET
HEARING FROM THE L, A Ó AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW THIS MONEY
IS GOING TO BE SPENT, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, I DIDN'T GET A
VERY GOOD ANSWER. I DID FIND OUT
THAT APPROXIMATELY THREE $0.6
BILLION WILL BE GOING TO
UNDOCUMENTED. FOLKS COMING INTO
OUR STATE, UH, THAT HAVEN'T
PARTICIPATED IN OUR TAX PROGRAMS
AND, UM AT THE SAME TIME, WE
HAVE MANY, UH LOCAL HOSPITALS,
AND WE HAVE MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID. UH, ISSUES WHERE THE
RATES AREN'T HIGH ENOUGH, SO I'M
ACTUALLY GONNA BE VOTING NÓ
TODAY. UM I DIDN'T WANT TO VOTE
NÓ. I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL DOLLARS. BUT IF WE'RE
JUST GONNA PUT IT IN THE GENERAL
FUND, AND WE'RE GONNA PUT IT
TOWARDS THINGS THAT DON'T
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR HEALTH CARE
AND ACTUALLY HELP KEEP OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS OPEN. THEN I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A DEEPER
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT. SO TODAY
I'LL BE VOTING NÓ. HOPEFULLY
BETWEEN NOW AND THE TIME WE
ACTUALLY DO THE FULL BUDGET, UH,
WE CAN FLUSH OUT SOME OF THESE,
UH, I THINK BIG ISSUES WHERE
WE'RE SPENDING MONEY ON, UH,
PROJECT ON USING A HEALTH CARE
TAX TO FUND THINGS THAT AREN'T
HEALTH CARE. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I WILL ACTUALLY BE
VOTING NÓ TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SENATOR. UM, LAIRD, YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. UM I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
REHASHING OLD GROUND, BUT IT
NEEDS TO BE REHASHED IN THE
LIGHT OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE, AND I REPRESENT A VERY
HIGH PROFILE, DISTRESSED
HOSPITAL. THIS ACTION TODAY WILL
NOT AFFECT THAT IN ANY WAY. WHEN
THIS WAS ENACTED THE FIRST TIME
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
WAS CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE, IT WENT 100% TO THE
GENERAL FUND. WHY DID IT GO TO
THE GENERAL FUND BECAUSE EVERY
OTHER PROGRAM WAS BEING CUT, AND
THIS IS OUR WAY TO NOT CUT ME AT
ALL. NOW WITH WHAT WE ADOPTED
LAST YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
YEARS, WE ARE RAISING RATES IN
SOME MEDICAL CATEGORIES,
SOMETHING THAT IS LONG OVERDUE.
THAT IS NOT TOUCHED BY THIS BILL
IN ANY WAY. AND THE FACT THAT
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LAST YEAR
AND THIS YEAR IS WE ARE
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF THE TAX
THAT EVEN THE PEOPLE THAT IT
APPLIES TO STOOD UP IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND SUPPORTED
BECAUSE IT DRAWS DOWN MORE MONEY
THAN THEY WILL PUT OUT FOR THE
TAX. AND SO THIS IS OUR WAY ONCE
AGAIN. OF NOT CUTTING ME IN THE
TIME OF A DEEP BUDGET CRISIS AND
OUR WAY TO PRESERVE THE RIGHT
INCREASES THAT WERE THERE, AND
IT IS TRADITIONAL NOT
NECESSARILY ALLOCATE THE TAX AT
THE TIME YOU ADOPTED. YOU ARE
DOING THE REVENUE. WE ARE ON THE
PATH TO BALANCING THE BUDGET.
THIS IS ONE STEP ON THE PATH TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET. THEN WHEN WE
COME BACK AFTER HOPEFULLY EARLY
ACTIONS AFTER THE BREAK AND LOOK
AT THE HARD DECISIONS WE HAVE TO
MAKE IN MAY AND JUNE, THIS WILL
BE IN PLACE. THIS WILL PROTECT
US FROM MAKING SOME SUBSTANTIAL
CUTS BY ENACTING THIS AND WE
HAVE TO DO IT BY THE FIRST OF
THE MONTH SO THAT IT GOES INTO
EFFECT AND WE CAN COUNT IT IN
THE BUDGET. THIS IS A GOOD
PROPOSAL. VOTING YES, WILL BE A
GOOD VOTE. IT DOES NOT HURT
HOSPITALS. IT IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO DO TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET. I ASKED FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
ALVARADO HèA YOU RECOGNIZED?
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY TO SPEAK, UH, IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL 136.
TYPICALLY YOU WOULD NOT HEAR ME
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF A TEXT.
HOWEVER THIS IS A SELF IMPOSED
TAX BY THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY.
UM THIS IS SUPPORTED BY THE
PEOPLE AND WOULD PAY UH, THE TAX
WOULD BE PAID BY THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY. UM, THERE IS NÓ
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. UH, WE
ARE SUPPORTING THIS BECAUSE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT DRAWDOWN OF
FEDERAL TAX DOLLARS. MATCH THAT
WILL BENEFIT OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM, AND WE NEED THIS IN THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES. WE NEED THIS
IN RURAL HEALTH, AND THAT'S WHY
I WOULD ASK FOR AN I VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. COLLEAGUES ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? NÓ SENATOR WEINER,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, MADAM.
CHAIR FIRST. I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ FOR, UH,
FOR HIS, UH, VERY, VERY, UH,
DETAILED AND ARTICULATE REMARKS.
UH, JUST TO BE CLEAR. UH, THIS
BILL AND THIS M èC Ó TAX AND
THE CHANGES WE'RE MAKING ARE
GOING TO STRENGTHEN ME. THEY
WILL STRENGTHEN ME AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE STABILIZE IT AND THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING THE FUNDING FOR
HEALTHCARE THAT WE NEED AND WE
HAVE A TRACK RECORD NOW OF DOING
THAT, UH, IN ADDITION, THIS IS
THE RESPONSIBLE THING TO DO AND
THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD DELAY
THIS CRITICAL PIECE OF OUR PATH
TOWARDS A BALLOT BUDGET. UM I
THINK IT WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE.
UH, WE SHOULD PASS THIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. OF
ROAD, GILL. HØI ARCHULETTA. HØI
ASHBY. BY ATKINS. I. BECKER. HØI
BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
HØI CORTEZ. DELHI. NÓ DODD. AY
TORAZO AYE EGM. I GLASER. HØI
GONZALEZ. I GROVE. HURTADO.
JONES. LAYERED HØI LIMÓN. HØI
MCGUIRE. AYE MIN. JAR. AYE MIN.
BY NEWMAN. I WIN. NILO. A DEAL.
HØI ARGENTINO. AYE, ROD. HØI
RUBIO. I SAY ARE TO NÓ SKINNER.
A SMALL QUAVERS. HØI STERN.
HAMBURG. AYE, WAHAB. HØI WIENER.
I WILL. NÓ SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENTEE MEMBERS. ALAN
BLAKESPEAR ROVE. JONES. WHEN
NILO. PA. ON THE URGENCY. ICE 29
NOS. THREE. THE ASSEMBLY AND
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. WE WILL MOVE
TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING FILE
ITEM 48 A B 1887 SITTER. WIENER.
ARE YOU PREPARED? SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1887
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
ARI TO STUDENT FINANCIAL AID AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
WEINER. YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. OUR
COLLEAGUES A B 1887 IS A BILL
RELATED TO THE FREE APPLICATION
FOR FEDERAL STUDENT AID OR FAFSA
. UH, MOST SIGNIFICANTLY. THE
BILL EXTENDS FOR THE 2024 TO 25
AWARD YEAR. ONLY THE PRIORITY
APPLICATION DEADLINE FOR STATE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION EXTENDS
IT TO MAY 2ND, UH AND FOR
CONTEXT, THE RECENT ROLL OUT OF
THE NEW FREE APPLICATION FOR
FEDERAL STUDENT AID IS CAUSING
DELAYS, BARRIERS AND
ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES FOR MANY
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS, UH MOST
PROMINENTLY IT IMPACTS STUDENTS
SEEKING TO ACCESS CAL GRANT AND
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AWARDS.
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE
SYSTEM, SO A WHOLE BUNCH OF
STUDENTS ARE NOT ABLE TO
ACTUALLY SUBMIT IT. UH AND SO WE
NEED TO DO THIS EXTENSION, UH,
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
APPLY. UH, RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR AN I VOTE. SENATOR LADY
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
UH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I JUST WANT
TO ADD THAT THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE NUMBER ONE HEARD
THIS ISSUE ON MARCH 7TH AND
BASICALLY WE WERE ABLE TO HEAR
IT TOGETHER WITH ALL OTHER
PROGRAMS ON STUDENT AID, AND
THIS IS NECESSARY FOR STUDENTS
TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GETTING AND
APPLY, AND AS A RESULT, YOU HAS
DELAYED THEIR APPLICATION
DEADLINE, AND I THINK OTHER
COLLEGES WILL AS WELL AND THIS
WILL ALLOW FOR THE FEDS TO
FINALLY TELL US WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO, AND STUDENTS TO
HAVE TIME TO KNOW IF THEY'RE
FULLY FUNDED BY THE APPLICATION,
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY THAT THIS WAS
HEARD AND DISCUSSED AT LENGTH
AND AT THE TIME, THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST SAID, YOU MAY WISH TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT'S IN THIS BILL SO I
WOULD REQUEST AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR COLLEAGUES ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? WE
KNOW YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A OVER. HØI ARCHULETA, HØI
ASHBY. HØI ATKINS. HØI BECKER.
BY BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. UH, CORTEZ. UH,
DALLY. ID. I DO RAZO. HØI EGM. I
GLAZER? AYE, GONZALEZ. I GROVE
AYE, BETAO. JONES. HØI LAYERED
HØI THEONE. AYE, MCGUIRE. HØI
MENJIVAR HIY MIN. I NEWMAN I
WIN. BY NEO IY. AYE. PER DIEM.
PINO. HØI ROTH. AYE, RUBIO. THEY
ARE, TOO HØI SKINNER. SMALL
QUAVERS STERN. HUMBERG AYE.
WELL, HØI WIENER. I WILL. AYE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
BLAKESPEAR. ON THE URGENCY, EYES
37 NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS, WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING
BACK TO OUR PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE IF
THE CENTER IS READY FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK OR FROM
HIS DESK. SENATOR UMBERG, YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. UM COLLEAGUES TODAY
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE JOINED WITH
FOLKS FROM THE GERMAN MARSHALL
FUND AND THE MEADOR FOUNDATION
FOR JOINING US TODAY AS PART OF
THE DIGITAL INNOVATION AND
DEMOCRACY INITIATIVE, AND I
WANTED TO INTRODUCE OUR HONORED
GUEST. UM, DOCTOR MOHAMMED. UH
SHAHEEM IS A MEMBER OF
PARLIAMENT FOR THE DUTCH SOCIAL
DEMOCRATS FOCUSING ON
ENVIRONMENTAL, HEALTH AND ENERGY
POLICIES AND IS KEY ADVOCATE FOR
THE EUROPEAN GREEN DEAL AND THE
CARBON BORDER ADJUSTMENT
MECHANISM. UM PETRIE. KAMPALA
NARI IS FROM FINLAND AND IS A
MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT EMPHASIZING
DIGITAL COOPERATIONS SUSTAINABLE
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS IN AN EU US
RELATIONSHIP WITH A DIGITAL AND
CLIMATE ADVOCACY, BACKGROUND.
DRAGOS TO, UH TO THE ARC. NAY Kò
. I'M SURE I MESSED THAT UP FROM
ROMANIA WITH MY APOLOGIES. UM IS
A MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT FROM VICE
PRESIDENT OF RENEW EUROPE HAS A
BACKGROUND IN LAW IN EU
INSTITUTIONS. HE FOCUSES ON
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE,
SECURITY AND TRANSATLANTIC
RELATIONS. PETER TAN AS A MEMBER
OF PARLIAMENT FROM BULGARIA
WORKS ON TRANSPORT TOURISM,
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES WITH A
SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
LEGISLATION. ZANA ZOKO IS FROM
THE REPUBLIC OF CROATIA. MEMBER
OF PARLIAMENT. UH ZOKO HAS A
DIPLOMATIC BACKGROUND AND IS
DEDICATED TO STRENGTHENING EU U
S¼ RELATIONS AND EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE IN INTERNATIONAL
DIPLOMACY. UH, THE FOUNDATION
FOSTERS A MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING
OF TECHNOLOGY POLICY, UH,
BUILDING ON RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN POLICY MAKERS,
INNOVATORS, INDUSTRY AND CIVIL
SOCIETY. PLEASE WELCOME THESE
FIVE EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT MEMBERS
WITH US TODAY IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
FIRST WE'RE GONNA HAVE SENATOR
UMBERG TAKE THAT PHOTO WITH HIS
HONORED GUEST AND THEN WE'LL
INVITE MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I NOW INVITE YOU IF YOU
WISH TO TAKE A PHOTO WITH OUR
GUESTS IN THE BACK.
MEMBERS IT'S GATHERED TOGETHER
IF YOU IF YOU WISH FOR THIS
PHOTO.
THAT'S A KEEPER.
MEMBERS. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED RED.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED RED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. SEE NONE. MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
YEAH. UH, SECOND READING FILE.
MR SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1025 WITH AMENDMENTS 1032
WITH AMENDMENTS 1095 WITH
AMENDMENTS. 11 Ó EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS 1209 1046 WITH
AMENDMENTS 11 AND 13 WITH
AMENDMENTS 971 WITH THE READING
IS DEEMED RED. MOVING ON TO
SECOND, UH, SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEM NUMBER 28. SENATOR
MENJIVAR. AND PLEASE READ.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION. 69 BY SENATOR
MINIBAR RELATIVE TO CESAR SHAVES
DAY. MEN MEN BY THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M
RISING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE LATINO
CAUCUS AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE, UM L GB Tð Q CAUCUS
IN HONOR IN THE LIFE OF LEGACY
OF CESAR CESAR E CHÁVEZ.
CHAVEZ'S LIFE SERVES AS AN
EXTRAORDINARY EXAMPLE OF HOW ONE
PERSON CAN HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON
ALL OF OUR LIVES. HE HE WAS A
SYMBOL OF JUSTICE AND EDUCATOR
OF CIVIL AND HUMAN RIGHTS AND A
ROLE MODEL. HE UNDERSTOOD THE
VALUE AND UNITY AND POWER OF
SOLID SOLIDARITY, HE FORGED A
NATIONAL SUPPORT COALITION OF
UNION CHURCH GROUPS, STUDENTS,
MINORITIES AND CONSUMERS THROUGH
THE USE OF BOYCOTTS AND
SPIRITUAL FAST. CESAR WAS ABLE
TO GAIN INVALUABLE RIGHTS FOR
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE, INCLUDING
OUR FARM WORKERS. TODAY THE
ROYAL FARM WORKERS IS JUST AS
VITAL TO THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA AS IT WAS WHEN CHÁVEZ
BEGAN HIS EFFORTS. OUR FARM
WORKERS CONTINUE TO FEED OUR
STATE AND NATION, AND THEY HAVE
ENABLED CALIFORNIA TO BECOME ONE
OF THE LARGEST, UM ECONOM E
ECONO ECON NÓ ECONOMIES.
ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT AND GROWTH OF
THE AR, UH, AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY. THESE, UM INVISALIGNS
ALWAYS CAUSED ME TO STUTTER. UH
CESAR CHÁVEZ USED TO SAY WE
CANNOT SEEK ACHIEVEMENT FOR
OURSELVES AND FORGET ABOUT
PROGRESS AND PROSPERITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. OUR AMBITIONS MUST BE
BROAD ENOUGH TO INCLUDE THE
ASPIRATION AND NEEDS OF OTHERS,
FOR THEIR SAKES, AND FOR OUR OWN
. JUST THIS LAST WEEKEND, MY
DISTRICT CELEBRATED, UH, THE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF MR CHÁVEZ BY
DOING A RALLY IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND ONE OF THE JOURNALISTS CAME
UP TO ME AND ASKED, WHY DO YOU
THINK THERE'S NOT ENOUGH ENERGY?
ENOUGH ENERGY AND RALLYING,
ADDRESSING INJUSTICES, AND I
CHALLENGE MY MEMBERS TO REMEMBER
THIS QUOTE BY CHÁVEZ THAT WE
MUST NOT FORGET. REGARDLESS OF
HOW FAR OUR AMBITIONS TAKE US OF
THE COMMUNITY AND THEIR ROOTS
FROM WHERE WE COME FROM THAT WE
MUST ALWAYS TURN BACK AND UPLIFT
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE THAT QUESTION THAT THE
JOURNALIST ASKED ME CHALLENGED
ME TO ENSURE THAT I FURTHER
ENGAGE AND EMPOWER AND ENERGIZE
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE IN MY
DISTRICT. LASTLY PLEASE FIND A
SPECIAL PRINT ON YOUR DESK ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS BY
ARTIST IGNACIO GÓMEZ. IGNACIO IS
THE ARTIST WHO PAINTED EL
PACHUCO, WHICH WAS USED AS THE
PRO AS THE POSTER FOR THE FIRST
CHICANO PLAY ON BROADWAY ZOO Z
BY LUIS VALDEZ. HE IS ALSO THE
DESIGNER AND SCULPTOR BEHIND THE
CESAR CHÁVEZ. RIVERSIDE
MEMORIAL. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. S¼ R
69 ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND ON BEHALF OF SO
MANY OF THE RESIDENTS IN MY
DISTRICT UM WHO, UH, COME FROM
THE SPIRIT OF CESAR CHÁVEZ, ONE
IN WHICH WE PUT THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTER, ONE IN WHICH THOSE MOST
IMPACTED, STAND TOGETHER AND
LIFT THEIR VOICE ONE IN WHICH
ONE COMMUNITY SPEAKS FOR JUSTICE
. UH, FOR ALL, UH, AS WE REFLECT
ON HIS LEGACY, CESAR CHÁVEZ NOT
ONLY HAD A PROFOUND IMPACT ON
THE RIGHTS OF FARM WORKERS, BUT
ALSO ON THE BROADER STRUGGLE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY. HE UNDERSTOOD THAT THE
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY
TRANSCENDS RACE. HE STOOD IN
SOLIDARITY WITH ALL AMERICANS
STRUGGLING FROM THE INJUSTICES
OF OPPRESSION, INCLUDING IN
PARTICULARLY SO WITH BLACK
AMERICANS. AND THOSE FROM
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, HIS COMMITMENT TO NON
VIOLENT RESISTANCE AND CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE WAS AN INSPIRATION
FOR SO MANY, PARTICULARLY
LEADERS LIKE DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING AND THE  N, A èC P WHO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FARM WORKERS
AND BLACK WORKING COMMUNITIES
SHARED THE SAME FIGHT AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND INEQUALITY IN
A 1966 TELEGRAM, DISS CHÁVEZ, DR
KING WROTE, THE FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY MUST BE FOUGHT ON MANY
FRONTS. IN THE URBAN SLUMS IN
THE SWEATSHOPS AND IN THE
FACTORIES AND FIELDS ARE
SEPARATE STRUGGLES ARE REALLY
ONE A STRUGGLE OF FREEDOM FOR
DIGNITY AND HUMANITY. UH A YEAR
AFTER THAT TELEGRAM, DR KING
LAUNCHED THE POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN, WHICH BROUGHT UH
PUERTO RICANS AND MEXICAN
AMERICANS BLACK AND POOR WHITES
TOGETHER TO FIGHT FOR ECONOMIC
JUSTICE. WE HONOR CESAR CHÁVEZ
HIS EXTRAORDINARY CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE SOCIAL JUSTICE MOVEMENT
AND THE LEGACY OF THAT STRUGGLE
IN ORGANIZATIONS TODAY THAT
CONTINUE THE FIGHT, PARTICULARLY
FOR FARM WORKERS. AS LEADERS OF
THE STATE. WE MUST ALWAYS
REMEMBER. UH THAT RESISTANCE IS
HOW WE CREATE CHANGE AND DOING
IT THROUGH CARE AND LOVE IS HOW
WE TRANSFORM GENERATIONS. AND
WITH THAT, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
GREEK SENATOR FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE AND SUPPORT OF S¼ R 69 ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA JEWISH
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AS AND ALSO
AS A DAUGHTER OF A FORMER
BRACERO FARM WORKER. UH, TODAY
WE HONOR A TIRELESS CRUSADER FOR
JUSTICE AND THE RIGHTS OF
WORKERS. CESAR CHÁVEZ WAS A
FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL FARM
WORKER ASSOCIATION, AND HIS
ACTIVISM CONTINUES TO BE A
GUIDING LIGHT FOR THE MOVEMENT,
AND HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN JUST
BRINGING PEACE AND HOPE TO SO
MANY IN THAT ERA THAT REALLY
JUST FOUND THEMSELVES STRUGGLING
TO GET RESPECT AND DIGNITY IN
THE WORKPLACE. THE LABOR
MOVEMENT HAS DEEP TIES WITH THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. MANY PIVOTAL
LABOR LEADERS ARE MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND JEWISH
COMMUNITY HAS LONG SUPPORTED
ORGANIZED LABOR AND THE RIGHTS
OF WORKERS WHEN THE NATIONAL
FARM WORKERS ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS TOOK TO THE STRIKE, THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY SUPPORTED AND
JOINED THEM AND SO MANY OF THEIR
ENDEAVORS, RABBIS DECLARED THE
NONUNION GRAVES A VIOLATION OF
THE RELIGIOUS TENETS NOT TO
STEAL AN ACTIVIST PARTICIPATED
IN STRIKES AND RALLIES. EVEN
LOSING THEIR LIVES AND THAT
STRUGGLE WITH THAT SAID, I WANT
TO REMEMBER NAN FREEMAN, AN 18
YEAR OLD JEWISH STUDENT WHO
JOINED THE PICKET LINES IN
SOLIDARITY AND WAS KILLED BY A
TRUCK PURPOSEFULLY DRIVEN
UNSAFELY THROUGH THE PICKET
LINE. NOT JUST JEWISH PEOPLE.
BUT MANY OTHER DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES ALSO MAY SACRIFICES
IN SOLIDARITY WITH CESAR CHÁVEZ
AND FARM WORKERS AS A DAUGHTER
OF A FORMER BRACERO, UM, WORKER
WHO, UH, DID A VERY HEAVY LABOR
AND YOU KNOW WHO TELLS ME
STORIES OF JUST, YOU KNOW, NOT
HAVING WATER WORKING LATE HOURS
IN THE SUN? UH, MANY HOURS. UM
HAS HAND JUST FULL OF CALLUSES.
I CAN THINK OF ALL THOSE THAT
STOOD IN SOLIDARITY. UH, NOT
ONLY THE JEWISH, UH BUT ALL
THOSE WHO SACRIFICE AT THAT TIME
AS WELL AND THEY PAID THE
ULTIMATE PRICE, SO MANY OF THEM
AND SO WITH THAT I THANK THEM,
UH, BECAUSE THAT BROUGHT
SOMEWHAT DIGNITY TO MY OWN
FATHER. UH THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
IS ALSO PROUD TODAY TO REAFFIRM
ITS SUPPORT FOR THE LABOR
MOVEMENT TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR EQUITY AND DIGNITY. AND OF
COURSE, REMEMBER, UH, THE LEGACY
OF CESAR CHÁVEZ MAY CESAR CHÁVEZ
MEMORY BE A BLESSING AND MAY WE
ALL CONTINUE TO EXPAND ON HIS
WORK. AS A PROUD CO-AUTHOR AND
ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS,
I URGE AND I VOTE ON S¼ R 69.
THANK YOU. SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT
. UM, I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY AND
PARTICULARLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE. UH WHICH I
REPRESENT, UM, APPROXIMATELY 80%
OF, UM AND SHARE THAT
REPRESENTATION. UM WITH TWO
COLLEAGUES, UH, HERE IN THE
SENATE, UH, WHO ALSO REPRESENT,
UH, PARTS OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE? YOU KNOW, CESAR LIVED IN
THE MAYFAIR NEIGHBORHOOD OF SAN
JOSE. IN THE HEART OF THE EAST
SIDE IN THE HEART OF
SENATE-DISTRICT 15. IT WAS IN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD, THE MAYFAIR
NEIGHBORHOOD. AT A CHURCH THAT'S
STILL THERE KNOWN AS OUR LADY OF
GUADALUPE, A CATHOLIC CHURCH
WHERE HE MET A FRANCISCAN PRIEST
, FATHER SOTO, WHO MENTORED
CESAR AND HELPED HIM CREATE, UH,
THE COMMUNITY SERVICE
ORGANIZATION, WHICH WAS THE
PREDECESSOR, OF COURSE TO HIS
HIS WORK IN FOUNDING OF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS WITH DOLORES
HIÆN AND OTHERS. UM MCDONNELL
HALL, UH, SITS ON THAT SITE. IT
WAS THE SITE OF ORGANIZING THEN
IT'S THE SITE OF HOUSING NOW AND
HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE, WITH THE STATE
HISTORIC MARKER AND BY THE
FEDERAL PARKS SYSTEM IN KIND
SEVERAL OF CAESAR'S FAMILY
MEMBERS STILL LIVE IN SAN JOSE.
MANY OF THEM MAINTAIN, UH, THE
SAN JOSE TRADITION OF THE LEGACY
OF CESAR CHÁVEZ TO THE NONPROFIT
CALLED, UH, THE CHÁVEZ FAMILY
VISION. UM, AND THAT INCLUDES,
UH, HIS ONE SURVIVING A SIBLING,
HIS SISTER, RITA CHÁVEZ MEDINA.
AND, OF COURSE, THE FAMILY IS
EXTREMELY PROUD OF THAT LEGACY.
OF THE MOVEMENT, UH, INCLUDING
THE FIRST LAUNCH OF THE GREAT
BOYCOTT AT THE SAFEWAY STORY AND
KING IN SAN JOSE. UH SO I WANTED
TO GET THAT ON THE RECORD, UM
AND, UH, APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING FORWARD THE RESOLUTION.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. UM
TO, UH, PARTICIPATE IN THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT TODAY AND I
WOULD URGE AND I VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. SENATOR
DE RAZZO. THANK YOU, MADAM.
PRESIDENT CESAR CHÁVEZ WAS A AN
EXTRAORDINARY HUMAN BEING. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING HIM
WALKING WITH HIM AND MARCHING
WITH HIM. BUT IT WAS MOSTLY
THROUGH HIS PERSONAL EXAMPLE
THAT HE TAUGHT US HOW TO LIVE
OUR LIVES IN CONNECTION WITH
EACH OTHER. IN LOVE OF ONE
ANOTHER. AND THE LOVE FOR OUR
WORLD. AND LOVE OF OUR COUNTRY.
AND LOVE OF FAMILY. AND THROUGH
HIS DEEP CATHOLIC FAITH. HE WAS
BEST KNOWN FOR WORKERS' RIGHTS.
THAT WORKING PEOPLE OUGHT TO GET
PAID FAIR WAGES AND NOT LIVE IN
POVERTY. HE TAUGHT US HOW TO
THROUGH WORKERS' RIGHTS, HOW TO
GET FAIR WORKING CONDITIONS. BUT
THERE ARE MANY, MANY OTHER
CAUSES THAT HE INTEGRATED INTO
HIS INTO THE STRUGGLES. FOR
EXAMPLE, HE WAS A TRUE
ENVIRONMENTALIST. NOBODY REALLY
TALKS ABOUT HIM AS AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST, BUT THROUGH A
UNION CONTRACT. DDT WAS BANNED
THE ONLY AND THE FIRST TIME THAT
WAS DONE THROUGH A UNION
CONTRACT, NOT THROUGH
GOVERNMENT. HE ALSO TAUGHT US
HOW TO WORK TOGETHER. AND THAT'S
DEMONSTRATED BY THE MANY REMARKS
THAT ARE MADE BY THE DIFFERENT,
UM, CAUCUSES HERE, BUT THERE ARE
PROBABLY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE. WHO WORKED ON HIS
CAMPAIGNS AND THE FARM WORKERS
CAMPAIGNS, WHETHER IN COALITION
JEWISH COMMUNITY, THE BLACK
COMMUNITY WOMEN'S MOVEMENT, THE
YOUTH MOVEMENT, UH, SPURRED AND,
UM TRIGGERED A CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AMONGST THE LATINO AND
MEXICAN AMERICANS IN THIS IN
THIS COUNTRY. SO I RISE TO ALSO
SUPPORT THIS, UM THIS RESOLUTION
AND WANT TO SAY GVA CESAR
CHÁVEZ. SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT, UH, ON BEHALF
OF AS VICE CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, I RISE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S¼ R 69 AND
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES PRIOR REMARKS ON THIS
GREAT MAN. UH, THIS HOLIDAY WAS,
OF COURSE, FIRST PROCLAIMED BY
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA IN 2014
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND CELEBRATE THE
LEGACY AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF
CESAR CHÁVEZ. UH NOW THERE'S A
LONG HISTORY OF COLLABORATION
BETWEEN CESAR CHÁVEZ AND MANY
ASIAN AMERICANS IN PARTICULAR
WITH THE FILIPINO AMERICAN
COMMUNITY, UH, INCLUDING UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF LARRY. UH, IT
IT LEONG TO FORM THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS OF AMERICA. CESAR
CHAVEZ'S COLLABORATION WITH THE
FILIPINO ORGANIZERS POINTS, THE
IMPORTANCE OF INTERSECTIONALITY
AND THE COLLABORATION THAT IS
POSSIBLE TO ACHIEVE A COMMON
GOAL BETWEEN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. NOW THIS DAY, I
THINK CELEBRATES MORE THAN JUST
CESAR CHÁVEZ. IT REALLY IS A
TRIBUTE, UH TO SEVERAL REALLY
IMPORTANT IDEAS THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO REALLY ACKNOWLEDGE
CLEARLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA. UH,
FIRST THAT WORKERS MATTER THAT
FARM WORKERS RIGHTS MATTER AND
THAT IMMIGRANT RIGHTS MATTER AND
THESE ARE TOUCHSTONES THAT I
THINK WE STILL NEED TO EMPHASIZE
TODAY AT A TIME WHEN WORKERS AND
IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING DEMONIZED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. I ALSO JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE PERSONAL
ROLE THAT CESAR CHÁVEZ HAS
PLAYED IN MY LIFE. UH MY WIFE
WOULD NOT HAVE EXISTED WITHOUT
CESAR CHÁVEZ. UH, MY MOTHER IN
LAW WAS A CATHOLIC NUN WHO LEFT
THE ORDER TO GO WORK FOR CESAR
CHÁVEZ IN KANSAS CITY AND MET
HER FUTURE HUSBAND AT A
FUNDRAISER FOR THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS. UH, APPARENTLY SHE WAS
THROWING UP MONEY IN THE AIR
BECAUSE THEY'D RAISED SO MUCH
AND IT WAS KIND OF AN EXCITING
THING. AND UH, THE YOUNG MAN
NEXT TO HER KIND OF RECOGNIZED
HER CELEBRATORY MOOD AND
INTRODUCED HIMSELF AND THAT A
LONG COURTSHIP THAT ENDED UP
WITH THEM GETTING MARRIED AND
HAVING MY WIFE. SO UH UH, REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT HE HAS DONE. UH,
INCLUDING PERSONALLY WITH THAT
IN MIND, UH, JUST WANNA
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS DAY OF
PUBLIC SERVICE IS ONE WHERE WE
SHOULD REMEMBER THAT THE USE OF
NONVIOLENT PEACEFUL PROTESTS ARE
SO IMPORTANT, UH, DURING THESE
TIMES, AND SO IT'S MY PRIVILEGE
IN JOINING MY COLLEAGUES TODAY
IN HONORING CESAR CHÁVEZ AND
ASKING FOR YOUR I VOTE ON S¼ R
69. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR MAN VARI MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
EVERYONE'S COMMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
OVERALL. BY ARCHULETA. I. ASHBY.
HØI ATKINS. HØI BECKER. AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD. AYE,
CABALLERO. I CORTEZ UH, DALLY.
HØI DODD. UH, TORAZO. HØI
EDMUND. I GLASER. GONZALEZ. I
GROVE. AY HURTADO. AYE, JONES. I
LAIRD I LIMÓN MCGUIRE AYE,
MINAR. BY MEN. BY NEWMAN. I WIN.
HØI NILO. I PATROL BOAT. HØI
PAD. I BENT DINO. I WROTE HØI
RUBIO. èC R TWO. HØI SKINNER.
AYE, SMALL CUEVAS. I START.
HUMBERG AYE, WAHAB. AYE, WEINER.
I WOKE HØI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BLAKESPEAR
RUBIO. HØI I 37 NÓ ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 37. SENATOR WAHAB
SHE IS PREPARED. PLEASE READ. UM
. CYNIC CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
126 BY SENATOR WAHAB RELATIVE TO
MELROSE. SENATOR HOVEY MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT
S¼ èC R 126 NARUS. I WANNA
THANK MY STAFF AND ESPECIALLY MY
CHIEF OF STAFF NERGIS FOR
CREATING THE SWEET GIFT BOXES
THAT ARE PLACED FOR EACH MEMBER
AND OTHER STAFF AS WELL AS THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE IRANIAN
AMERICAN DEMOCRATS OF CALIFORNIA
FOR SETTING UP THE HAVE SEEN
ROOM IN ROOM 317, WHICH ALL OF
YOU ARE WELCOME TO POST SESSION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATED
WORK TO THIS BEAUTIFUL CULTURAL
CELEBRATION. NOWRUZ WHICH
DIRECTLY TRANSLATES TO NEW DAY
AND AS A CULTURAL CELEBRATION OF
THE FIRST DAY OF SPRING AND OUR
NEW YEAR'S IT'S CELEBRATED ON
THE VERNAL EQUINOX, WHICH VARIES
FROM YEAR TO YEAR AND ACROSS THE
GLOBE IN 2010, THE UNITED
NATIONS DECLARED MARCH 21ST AS
INTERNATIONAL DAY OF NAZ. THE
NEW DAY SYMBOLIZES A COMMITMENT
TO SPRINGTIME RENEWAL, PEACE AND
OVERALL SOLIDARITY BETWEEN
GENERATIONS, FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. NAURU IS
COMMEMORATES THE NEW YEAR FOR
MANY AFGHAN AND CENTRAL ASIAN
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE WORLD.
NARO WAS CELEBRATED BY MORE THAN
THREE 100 MILLION PEOPLE. AROUND
THE WORLD FOR MORE THAN 3000
YEARS AND OVER 23 COUNTRIES,
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES,
WHERE NAZ IS CELEBRATED,
CELEBRATED BY AMERICANS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS, REGARDLESS OF
RELIGION. INCLUDING THOSE WITH
BAHAI, FAITH, CHRISTIAN, JEWISH,
MUSLIM, ZOROASTRIAN AND
NON-RELIGIOUS BACKGROUNDS. THE
UNITED STATES. CENSUS REPORTS
THE LARGEST POPULATIONS OF
AFGHANS OUTSIDE OF AFGHANISTAN
TO LIVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT 54% OF IRANIAN IMMIGRANTS
IN AMERICA LIVE IN CALIFORNIA,
AND NOWRUZ SERVES TO REMIND US
ALL OF THE MANY LASTING
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE PERSIAN
CIVILIZATION TO THE WORLD. WE
ARE NOT WHAT IS DEPICTED IN THE
MEDIA. WE ARE MORE THAN THAT.
AND THE NOTEWORTHY IMPACT OF
AFGHAN AMERICANS TO THE SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC FABRIC OF SOCIETY
IN THE UNITED STATES AND THE
WORLD WHERE AFGHANISTAN WAS HOME
TO THE OLDEST OIL PAINTINGS IN
THE WORLD, WHERE THE WORLD'S
BEST SELLING POET IS RUMI FROM
BACH IN AFGHANISTAN AND
INCLUDING ONE OF THE EARLIEST
EXPRESSIONS OF HUMAN RIGHTS IN
THE WORLD. THE CYRUS CYLINDER OF
CYRUS THE GREAT, WHICH CALLED
FOR THE FREEDOM OF SLAVES,
REPARATIONS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
AND PRACTICE YOUR OWN FAITH AND
RACIAL EQUITY. AS WELL AS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF IRANIAN
AMERICANS TO THE EVER GROWING
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC TAPESTRY OF
OUR COUNTRY AFTER THOUSANDS OF
YEARS IN THE MAKING NOW, ROSE
REMAINS BELOVED UNIVERSAL AND
DEEPLY EMBEDDED IN PERSIAN
CULTURE. IT IS A CELEBRATION OF
PEACE AND NEIGHBORLINESS. THESE
IDEALS WE MUST STRIVE AND FIGHT
FOR PEACE IS NOT A PASSIVE
STATE, BUT AN ACTIVE COMMITMENT
TO EACH OTHER. TO CHOOSE A PATH
THAT MAY REQUIRE MORE WORK MORE
CONSENSUS BUILDING, BUT THAT
YIELDS REWARDS FAR GREATER THAN
WE CAN IMAGINE. ON THIS NOW,
ROSE. I LOOK FORWARD TO A NEW
YEAR A NEW DAY FILLED WITH PEACE
. MAY YOU ALWAYS BE HAPPIER THAN
DIDOS YESTERDAY. LUCKIER THAN
AMBROSE TODAY AND BLESSED AROS
EVERY DAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. UM, SENATOR, MEN YOU
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND, UH, THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES UM AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
IS A CO-AUTHOR OF S¼ èC R 126.
I'M PROUD TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING
NAURU'S OR NAURU, AS I SAID IN
FARSI, UH, THE BEGINNING OF
PERSIAN NEW YEAR. NOW I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TERRIBLE EVENTS
THAT ARE HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
IRAN, THE DEATH AND MURDER OF
MASSA AMINI, UH, THE CRACKDOWN
ON WOMEN'S RIGHTS. UH THE
HORRIBLE TORTURES, ABDUCTIONS,
RAPES AND MURDERS OF SO MANY
WOMEN AND GIRLS. UH, THIS IS A
HORRIFIC SET OF EVENTS AND IS
ONE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
ACKNOWLEDGING HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY. UM I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE IN MANY WAYS THAT NÓ
RULES THIS YEAR FALLS, UH,
DURING AS EVERY YEAR DURING
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH, AND WE DO
ALL WE CAN TO TRY TO RESTORE
WOMEN'S RIGHTS THERE. AND I JUST
WANNA SAY WOMEN LIFE FREEDOM OR,
AS THEY SAY IN FARSI, ZEN ZEND
AZADI. UH, THIS IS A VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT MESSAGE THAT WE NEED
TO REINFORCE HERE. UH, BUT NÓ R
IS A CELEBRATION OF REBIRTH AND
OF PEACE. AS MY COLLEAGUE, UM,
MENTIONED AND, UH, I THINK IT'S
ALSO A TIME OF CELEBRATION. UH,
IT'S A TIME WHEN PEOPLE FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE ARE SUPPOSED TO
COME TOGETHER IN A SPIRIT OF
INCLUSIVITY, DIVERSITY, UNITY,
PROSPERITY AND JOY. AND I THINK
THAT AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED,
CALIFORNIA IS A REFLECTION OF
THIS WONDERFUL DIVERSITY THAT WE
APPRECIATE HERE. UH AND SO I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT ME IN AND JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING S¼ èC R. UH,
126. I ALSO WANT WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, UH, SEVERAL OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO CAME UP FROM
ORANGE COUNTY TO HELP CELEBRATE
NÓ R HERE. UH, SEVERAL IRANIAN
AMERICANS. WE HAVE F HAZAR UH,
ALEX MOHAIR AND SUDI FRO, UH,
WHO CAME UP TO CELEBRATE HERE?
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING UP,
AND, UH NÓ ROZ MUBARAK. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SENATOR
RAHAB. YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
NOW, ROSE MUBARAK. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEE
NONE. I 37 NÓ ZERO. RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS IS
THERE. IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SEE
NONE. SECRETARY. FOR A PURPOSE
RIGHTS. A POINT OF ORDER, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATOR. WERE YOU
STATE? THE POINT OF ORDER?
EARLIER TODAY WE ADOPTED TWO
MEASURES ON OUR UNFINISHED
BUSINESS, BOTH OF THEM URGENCY
MEASURES. AFTER THE COMPLETION
OF THE VOTE. YOU ANNOUNCED THAT
THERE WAS A TWO THIRDS VOTE ON
THE URGENCY. BUT YOU SAID
NOTHING ABOUT THE UNDERLYING
MEASURE AND WHETHER IT PASSED OR
NOT ON BOTH MEASURES LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE IMPORTANT
MEASURES ARE APPROPRIATELY
APPROVED AND WOULD LAST THAT WE
CHECK TO MAKE SURE THE RULES
HAVE BEEN PROPERLY FOLLOWED.
ACTUALLY TRUE. GLACIER THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING UP THOSE
POINTS OF ORDER. I'D LIKE TO
REASSURE YOU ON BOTH MEASURES ON
THEIR URGENCY. I ANNOUNCE THE
AYES AND THE NOSE AND FOLLOWING
THAT I DID ANNOUNCE THE
AMENDMENT. CONCURRENT
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
WERE CONCURRED IN SO ORDER WAS
FOLLOWED TERRIFIC. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. RETURNING TO
THE WE TURN TO ORDER. DO WE HAVE
ANY MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SENATOR SENATOR CABELLO? YOU
RECOGNIZED YES, MÀ. UH, MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST WANTED TO SEE IF
AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION IS
APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME. NOT AT
THIS TIME. COMING UP SOON,
SENATOR.
COLLEAGUES GOING BACK TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IS THERE ANY
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? NON SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ SOME CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
1 39 1 43 ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 145. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
FIRST ITEM. I RATHER G. HØI
ARCHULETTA HØI ASHBY. I ATKINS I
BECKER AY BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. UH, DALLY.
DODD. TOO. HØI EGM. I GLASER.
GONZALEZ. I GROW. AYE, BETAO.
JONES. I LAYERED LEMON. HØI
MCGUIRE. HØI MY JAR. I MEAN,
NEWMAN. I WIN. AYE, NILO. OVER.
NEELA, I PAD I ARGENTINO. HØI
RO. HØI RUBIO. I SAY ARE TWO I.
SKINNER. BY SMALL QUIVERS I
STERN UMBERG. AYE, WAHAB.
WINNER. AYE, WIL. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BLAKESPEAR STERN. W. BUT I
WEINER OR EXCUSE ME, WILK. LOOK,
I. ICE 37 KNOWS ZERO CONSENT
CALENDARS APPROVED MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE JUMPING BACKWARDS A
LITTLE BIT AND GOING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR
I'M FORGETTING EVERYBODY'S NAME.
SENATOR BECKER. FOR WHAT REASON
DO YOU RISE? UM, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. UH, IT'S COME
TO MY ATTENTION TODAY IS
INTERNATIONAL FOREST DAY. IT'S
ALSO INTERNATIONAL. UH UH UH, IN
THIS NATIONAL COMMON COURTESY
DAY AND ALSO WORLD POETRY DAY,
SO IN HONOR OF THAT, UM, I'D
LIKE TO READ A SERIES OF POEMS
AND I'D LIKE THEIR PERMISSION TO
READ. SENATOR GIVEN THE FACT
THAT I WAS ALSO A SUB THREE
CHAIR MEMBER, AND THEN WE'RE
PROBABLY GONNA BE HERE TILL THE
WEE LATE HOURS OF THE NIGHT. I
WILL NOT BE GRANTING THAT
PERMISSION AND WE WILL BE MOVING
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
IT WAS AN HONOR OF YOUR, UH,
PRESIDENCY TODAY. I HAD WRITTEN
A POEM FOR YOU. BUT ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR DOLLY FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON
CONDITION OF THE FILE. SENATOR
DOLLY THE PROPER TIME TO SPEAK
ON THE MO ON THE CONDITION OF
THE FILE IS RIGHT BEFORE. UH
RIGHT BEFORE WE ADJOURN. I'LL
TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY, THEN.
THANK YOU. THE INTERGLACIAL YOU
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM.
PRESIDENT, I I'D LIKE TO CALL A
CAUCUS, PLEASE.
MHM. SENATOR WE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO CAUCUS RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
GONNA BE MOVING BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. AND IF
WE ALL WISH TO STAY HERE LONGER,
I WELCOME YOU TO JOIN MY SUB
THREE MEETING THAT WILL BE HERE
TILL PROBABLY SEVEN, OR 8 P.M.
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THIS ISSUE? SENATOR BECKER,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED, MADAM
PRESIDENT. BUDGET SUB TWO WILL
ROOM IN, UH, MEETING ROOM 2200
IN THE SWING SPACE 15 MINUTES
AFTER ADJOURNMENT. BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE. NUMBER THREE WILL
MEET 50 MINUTES AFTER SESSION IN
ROOM 1200 SENATOR WILL HAVE YOU
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, UH, SUB
FIVE WILL MEET IN THE STATE
CAPITOL ROOM. 1 1215 MINUTES
AFTER ADJOURNMENT. COLLEAGUES
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO. WE'RE
MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS THE TIME
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING
DOING OUR AD JOURNEY MEMORIES. I
ASK RESPECTFULLY, WE CAN BE
GOING IF WE CAN GO BACK TO OUR
SEATS. THE FASTER WE DO THIS
AGAIN, THE FASTER WE GO TO OUR
SUBCOMMITTEES, AND YOU CAN ALL
ENJOY YOUR SPRING RECESS. WE'RE
GONNA START FIRST WITH SENATOR
NILO. COLLEAGUE SENATOR NE NILO
IS GONNA START WITH HIS
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY. I ASK ONCE
AGAIN IF WE CAN TAKE OUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR OR
REMAIN IN OUR SEATS SILENT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. UNO. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND LET ME ADD THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN, UM UH, TAKING
THIS, UH, ABUSE FROM OUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUES WITH GRACE AND
DIGNITY AND ALL OF THAT,
NOTWITHSTANDING, YOU'RE DOING AN
OUTSTANDING JOB. SO UM, I AM
ADJOURNING TODAY IN THE MEMORY
OF, UH, FRED HAROLD. LOCAL CAR
DEALER FRED REALLY KNOWN BY HIS
FRIENDS AS FRITZ, HAROLD. PASSED
AWAY. UH, THIS LAST OCTOBER,
18TH. HE WAS BORN IN ATASCADERO,
BUT HE SPENT MOST OF HIS LIFE IN
SACRAMENTO. HE WAS A LOVING AND
LOVED HUSBAND, FATHER,
GRANDFATHER, GREAT GRANDFATHER.
UH AND REALLY GOOD FRIEND TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND HE WAS TRULY
PILLAR OF OUR COMMUNITY. AFTER
SERVING IN THE ARMY AIR CORPS AT
THE END OF WORLD WAR I HE
ATTENDED THE COLLEGE OF PACIFIC
NOW THE UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC,
AFTER WHICH HE AND HIS BROTHER
EDWIN, FOR FOUNDED THE NORTHERN
ENGINEERING COMPANY. AN ENGINE
REMANUFACTURING. UH COMPANY
AFTER SOME YEARS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH HIS BROTHER, HE JOINED HIS
OTHER BROTHER, ELMER, TO RUN
HAROLD FORD, FOUNDED BY THEIR
FATHER, ELLSWORTH IN 1911. THAT
DEALERSHIP ACTUALLY STILL EXISTS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO UNDER
DIFFERENT OWNERSHIP ON HOW
AVENUE AS I SAID, HE WAS TRULY A
PILLAR OF OUR COMMUNITY, HAVING
SERVED ON BOARDS AND LOCAL
BOARDS OF LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS, SUCH AS THE
SACRAMENTO CHILDREN'S HOME, THE
SACRAMENTO S¼ P èC, A AND THE
SACRAMENTO METRO CHAMBER AND A
FEW LOCAL BUSINESSES SUCH AS
PATTERSON AIRCRAFT AND CAPITAL
BANK OF COMMERCE. HE WAS ALSO
NAMED SIGNIFICANTLY AS A PAUL
HARRIS. FELLOW FELLOW ROTARIANS
WILL KNOW THAT THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT, UM, OF
SPECIAL IMPORTANCE TO HIM WAS
HIS CHURCH HOME PIONEER
CONGREGATIONAL CHURCH, WHERE HE
SERVED AS PRESIDENT. I KNEW
FRITZ BECAUSE I WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL WITH HIS SON. RITZ JUNIOR
, UH, WHO I WILL BE INTRODUCING,
UH, IN A MOMENT. HE IS IN THE
GALLERY, BUT I REALLY GOT TO
KNOW FRITZ. AS A FELLOW CAR
DEALER. AND LATER STILL AS A
FELLOW MEMBER, ALONG WITH MY DAD
OF THE INFORMAL, OLD UM I CAN'T
SAY THAT. LET'S JUST SAY, OLD
FELLOWS FLATULENCE CLUB. HIS
OBITUARY SAID HE HAD A SPECIAL
WAY. ABOUT HIM, LISTENED WELL
AND MADE PEOPLE FEEL SPECIAL. I
KNEW AND EXPERIENCED THAT.
FIRSTHAND. OF PARTICULAR NOTE
ABOUT FRITZ. WAS HIS
IMMEASURABLE COMPASSION. HE
SHOWED THAT MOST IN HIS WORK
WITH SUTTER HOSPICE. WHERE HE
SPENT PRECIOUS HOURS HIS AND THE
PATIENTS. VOLUNTEERING WITH END
OF LIFE. CARE PATIENTS. NOW EACH
OF YOU MAY LEARN ABOUT THIS, UH,
BY, UH, A VIEWPOINTS COLUMN THAT
I EMAILED TO EACH ONE OF YOU WAS
NOT, UNFORTUNATELY, NOT ABLE TO
PUT IT ON THE DESKS. AND IF YOU
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO READ
THAT I DO HAVE A FEW EXTRAS
HERE. BUT I CHALLENGE YOU. TO
READ THAT. AND NOT BE
EMOTIONALLY MOVED. THAT WAS RITZ
HERALD. HE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH
BY HIS LOVING WIFE OF 62 YEARS.
ERDA HIS SIBLINGS EDWIN ELMA, UH
, ELMER AND MARTHA MCBRIDE, WITH
WHOM HE WAS PARTICULARLY CLOSE
AND BY THE WAY, MARTHA'S HUSBAND
, TOM MCBRIDE WAS A MEMBER OF
OUR STATE ASSEMBLY, UH, IN THE
19 FIFTIES. HE'S SURVIVED BY TWO
SONS, FRITZ JUNIOR AND CHRIS AND
THEIR WIVES. RITU AND JUDY. ALSO
TWO GRANDCHILDREN AND FIVE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. AND NOW ALLOW ME
TO INTRODUCE TO YOU A FRITZ,
RITO AND CHRIS, WHO ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY IN THE GALLERY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. AGAIN.
JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN MEMORY
OF FRED FRITZ HAROLD. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. FOR THOSE BEAUTIFUL
WORDS, PLEASE BRING HIS NAME UP
SO THAT HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIZED IN THE JOURNAL SENATOR
ASHBY YOU RECOGNIZE ON THIS?
THANK YOU. I JUST WANNA RISE AS
THE OTHER SENATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO. AND WHILE I DO NOT
KNOW THE HAROLD FAMILY AS WELL
AS THE NELO FAMILY DOES MY
COLLEAGUE ALSO FROM SACRAMENTO.
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS FAMILY
IS TO YOU. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THE ARTICLE WITH US.
I READ IT. IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
UH, SENATOR FROM NAPA AND I WERE
JUST DISCUSSING HOW WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE LIFE A PERSON WHO
WOULD SPEND THEIR SPARE TIME
GOING TO HOSPICE TO HELP OTHER
PEOPLE WITH TRANSITION AND FIND
TRUE JOY AND ENLIGHTENMENT IN
THAT PROCESS, AND I JUST WANNA
THANK THE FAMILY FOR ALL THEY DO
FOR THE SACRAMENTO REGION FOR
THE MANY, UH ASSOCIATIONS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU ALL ARE
INVOLVED WITH. AND THANK YOU,
SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO. MY
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE FOR HELPING
US HONOR YOUR FRIEND. THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO OUR SECOND AD
JOURNEY IN MEMORY. IF CENTER
CORTESE IS PREPARED THESE PROCE
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT IF I MAY ON A PERSONAL
POINT OF PRIVILEGE I WANTED TO,
UM, ACKNOWLEDGE YOU FOR YOUR
NONVIOLENT FORBEARANCE IN THE
SPIRIT OF CESAR CHÁVEZ NOT
HAVING COME DOWN ON THE FLOOR TO
ACCOST ANYBODY EARLIER. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. UM, I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF BENTON
WHITE, A LONG TIME SAN JOSE
RESIDENT WHO PASSED PEACEFULLY
IN DECEMBER AT THE AGE OF 92, HE
WAS BORN IN BIRMINGHAM, ALABAMA,
AND MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE.
MARY LOU IN NEBRASKA. IN 1961,
THEY MOVED TO SAN JOSE. TOGETHER
HE TOOK ON THE ROLE OF METHODIST
CAMPUS MINISTER FOR SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY. I THINK HE'D
BE JUSTIFIABLY PROUD TO BE
RECOGNIZED ON CESAR CHÁVEZ DAY
HE WAS A PROGRESSIVE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVIST RECRUITING
STUDENTS TO JOIN THE FREEDOM
SUMMER OF 1964. BENTON'S ROLE AS
AN ORGANIZER IN THE INVOLVEMENT
OF THESE STUDENTS IN VOTER
REGISTRATION DRIVES WERE
VALUABLE TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IN THE SOUTH. THIS IMPACT
EXTENDED NATIONWIDE AND
CONTRIBUTED TO A SHIFTING
NARRATIVE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. HE
WAS FROM THE SOUTH. SO HE GREW
UP SEEING THESE INEQUITIES. BEN
WAS NOT ONLY SAN JOSE STATE'S
FIRST OMBUDSMAN IN 1967. HE WAS
THE NATION'S FIRST THE ROLE WAS
CREATED IN RESPONSE TO HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINTS FROM
STUDENTS OF COLOR. AT THE TIME
THE CAMPUS HAD SEGREGATED
SORORITIES AND FRATERNITIES. HE
ACTED AS A LIAISON BETWEEN
STUDENTS AND THE ADMINISTRATION.
HE PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN
PROMOTING INSTITUTIONAL CHANGE
TO SERVE MARGINALIZED STUDENTS.
BEN ALSO ESTABLISHED THE
SCHOOL'S RELIGIOUS STUDIES
PROGRAM IN 1970. HE WAS AN
ACCOMPLISHED SCHOLAR WHOSE
EDUCATION INCLUDED ATTENDING THE
CHANDLER SCHOOL OF THEOLOGY AT
EMORY UNIVERSITY AND PACIFIC
LUTHERAN THEOLOGY THEOLOGICAL
SEMINARY. HE WAS AN AIR FORCE
CHAPLAIN IN THE STRATEGIC AIR
COMMAND AS WELL. BEEN RETIRED
FROM SALES ESTATE IN 1992 AFTER
31 YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE
CAMPUS. EVEN IN HIS RETIREMENT.
HE CONTINUED TO SERVE HIS
COMMUNITY. HE SPENT HIS TIME
TEACHING AS AN ADJUNCT PROFESSOR
AT SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY, AND
HE LOVED TO TRAVEL AND SPEND
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY. BEN'S
RELATIONSHIPS INCLUDED, UH,
SEVERAL OF MY FAMILY MEMBERS AND
HIS OWN. ONE OF HIS SONS, TOM
WHITE, IS WELL KNOWN AROUND THE
CAPITOL. HE IS A FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF OF MY OWN FATHER. UH, SOME
DOMINIC CORTEZ. AND OF COURSE,
THOMAS SERVED IN SEVERAL
POSITIONS. ADMIRABLY HERE IN THE
CAPITOL OVER THE YEARS. BEEN WAS
FIRST AND FOREMOST A
CONSTITUENT. I REPRESENTED HIM
AS A STATE SENATOR, OF COURSE,
BUT BEFORE THAT, AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR BEFORE THAT, AS A
RESIDENT OF MY CITY COUNCIL
DISTRICT AND BEFORE THAT, AS A
CONSTITUENT OF MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT, GOING BACK TO 1992.
BUT THE RELATIONSHIPS, OF COURSE
, GO BACK BEFORE EVEN THEN, AS
THEY JUST NOTED. IT WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR HIS CONTRIBUTIONS
TO SALES STATE AND THE BROADER
COMMUNITY IN MY DISTRICT. WHEN
BEN CALLED RETURNED HIS PHONE
CALL. OH, MISS HIS CALLS. BUT
HIS ACTIVISM AND THE ROLE MODEL
HE SET AS AN ACTIVIST.
CONSTITUENT AND LEADER IN OUR
DISTRICT WILL BE FOREVER
REMEMBERED. A PROFOUND IMPACT ON
THE LIVES OF EVERYONE AROUND
HIM. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE.
IN ADDITION TO HIS SON, TOM,
ANOTHER SON, ANOTHER SON, THREE
GRANDCHILDREN, AND ONE GREAT
GRANDCHILD. HE WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED. THANK YOU AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. FOR THOSE LOVELY WORDS,
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
HE MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIZED IN
THE JOURNAL. UH, SENATORS, UH,
BEFORE WE ADJOURN, THERE IS A
NAURU'S RECEPTION IN ROOM THREE
17 FOLLOWING THIS RECEPTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR E. ENERGETIC
VIBES THIS MORNING. UH AS I
PRESIDED FOR THE FIRST TIME, I
WELCOMED THEM BACK. UH, MOVING
FORWARD. MAYBE NOT BERNIE SO
MUCH. UM, IF THERE IS NÓ OTHER
BUSINESS, SENATOR MAGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
, MADAM PRESIDENT, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, I WANT TO SAY, MADAM
PRESIDENT. FANTASTIC JOB TODAY,
AND I KNOW THIS IS OUT OF ORDER.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO GIVE, UH,
PRESIDENT OF OUR ROUND OF
APPLAUSE. DUCKING AND DIVING AND
HOLDING FOR THE ENTIRE TIME. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS HOPE THAT YOU
HAVE A WONDERFUL BREAK. YOU'RE
ABLE TO SPEND TIME WITH FRIENDS
AND FAMILY. I KNOW MOST OF YOU
ARE GOING TO BE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITIES DOING THE GOOD WORK
EACH AND EVERY DAY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA MADAM
PRESIDENT IN THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY.
APRIL 1ST AT 2 P.M. NÓ FOOLING.
TURN IT BACK OVER TO YOU. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL MONDAY, APRIL 1ST 2024
AT 2 P.M.